just no passion in them right and then
on top of it they're completely
unrecognizable it's the the political
message is like very ham-fisted
um I you know it's unclear to me why
there hasn't been a Tipping Point
already because people just aren't like
audiences just aren't enjoying these new
these new films right like there's no
there's no appeal to them as far as like
Ziegler's comments being some sort of uh
Tipping Point maybe
um especially because it feels like she
herself somehow has like created this
cottage industry of like Angry 30 signs
like I was looking I was looking through
tip talk when this just happened and
it's like if you just type in Rachel
Ziegler's name it's like
every person who was born after between
like between like 1986 and like 1994 was
just like so pissed at her I've never
seen anything like it and meanwhile
Zoomers were kind of just like we
weren't going to see this movie anyway